so it's Friday evening tonight I wanted
to share a quickly a paper that is
slightly outside of the usual suspect
but I found really cool this paper
called role play with large language
model it was published nature just last
week and the author it's really funny
because one of them is is the is muray
Shanahan at Deep M you know the large
scale organization that basically
invented AI somehow with open AI couple
of them and the other two Kyle McDonald
and Laria Reynolds they are both at elu
so very different like this Collective
of hacker now a nonprofit but I found
really cool that these two world
collaborate and work together so what
has the paper talk about it talk about
how can we think about llm how can we
think about L langage and what's the
problem well the problem is we use words
like understand know think all all these
words are very loaded by the psychology
of human but human learn language very
differently where in this unbodied world
talking with family while large language
model they learn by predicting the most
plausible next token in a very large
Corpus that cover the whole internet and
so how can we talk about large language
models without falling in this
anthropomorphism without you know using
these words that basically just don't
mean the same thing that they mean
for human uh and so what the paper says
that we we should see models as role
player and how does it work when when
you interact with chpt when you interact
with and even with a pre-trained model
which is actually maybe more what these
papers are is about um you have a prompt
you have a beginning of a dialogue
basically where there is kind of an
interaction between two users and then
you ask a question and the model will
try to predict the most PL continuation
that means the next word given all this
interaction in all this interaction they
kind of divine they kind of Define a
role you know they Define someone
basically a character who would fits the
description of the Preble and might say
the sort of things that were said before
and the model will try to R play this
character as well as it can as
portraited in the prompt where does the
model find these roles this role play
plays it find them in a training data
set because in a training data set you
have like Noels you have screenplay you
have biographies you have interviews you
have newspapers you have a whole vast
repositories repertoire of archetypes of
narrative structures with love triangle
with Rog AI with gentle AI um and all of
these Define roles and the model will
try to find the most relevant one that
might have said what was said in the
beginning and continue as this world
might
continue and a good way to think about
that is actually not to think about that
as a singal role but to think about that
as a superposition of role a bit like a
Quantum superposition you know and there
is a very nice example that they show
which is the game of the 20 question you
know this game where you have to select
well actually in this case that would be
the model have to select an object and
then you will ask yes or no answer and
the model will answer yes or no and you
know this will go through several
question until you reach the object the
many interface that you use to interact
with this model you can reind and you
can regenerate answers right
and you can have different answers then
you can go to different objects and that
would not have any sense if actually you
were you know model was doing as us
which was selecting an object and can
committing to it uh but what activ mono
is doing is every time is generating a
new answer that's coherent with all the
previous answers okay and that's
basically Define more and more the role
so it start with every object being
basically possible and then they will
become as you go through the dialogue
less and less objects you know until you
have to find one and that's really how
you can see these models let's explain a
lot of things also that we see so when
you jailbreak a model you know when you
make it you know say thing that's not
supposed to say it's not like you're
reaching the real nature of the model as
some people are saying it's more like
you're just moving to another role
basically and it's roll all the way down
SW play all the way down just like
turtles so it might seem obvious to
people who are using l but I think it's
not something that's really in the
mainstream discussion enough and that's
really one way we should teach you know
to Young Generation or to people who are
joining AI I think that's one way we
could teach AI you know as as a full
roleplay total role play uh agent it
also doesn't mean that it's very uh safe
because obviously when the model
interact with objects and with you know
the real world if it's playing the bad
role you don't you don't want to have
that right so does a doesn't really
change I would say ethical question but
it Chang a lot of things around
anthropomorphism and self-preservation
of self-awareness because all of these
are basically just the model you know
answering as the role in a training data
set are and these worlds are just human
a human want self-preservation they want
they are self-aware and some human can
lie and that's fake news so all of this
can help us I think understand a little
bit better you know or at least talk
about this model a little bit
better